cruel daca fue aprobado por la
presidencia pero el congreso nunca creó
una ley para darle ciudadanía a los
jóvenes migrantes y ahora una corte de
apelación discute una demanda del estado
de texas que impide la aplicación del
programa en toda esta incertidumbre
legal cuéntenos qué está pasando con los
dreamers y cuál es el riesgo que
enfrentan
bueno como tú bien mencionaste en el
programa de acá está en un camino muy
peligroso hacia la corte suprema una
corte suprema muy conservadora con tres
jueces de la corte suprema que fueron
fueron nombrados por el presidente el
pasado presidente pero en el programa de
acá podría terminar y entonces estamos
sonando las alarmas hablándole tanto al
congreso como al presidente mailén para
encontrar una una salida permanente a
este problema no solamente para los
jóvenes que tienen daca sino también
para aquellas personas que no han
calificado para el programa porque hay
muchas personas que se han quedado fuera
entonces el momento de ahora es sonar
las alarmas porque está en camino están
seguimos en esta batalla legal y bueno
como tú sabes posiblemente llegando a
una corte supema muy conservadora y con
el fin de un programa que es tan exitoso
con el programa daca bueno y esta
batalla legal de la existen nos habla
también tiene una unión con la política
en este sentido que tanto afectarían las
elecciones de medio término en noviembre
al daca
bueno como todos sabemos muchos esperan
de que los demócratas que hoy tienen una
mayoría que hoy podrían actuar que hoy
podrían hacer algo por los jóvenes
inmigrantes pues es posible que pierdan
su mayoría simple
la verdad es lamentable que los
demócratas no hayan podido hasta ahora
utilizar el poder que tienen para poder
ponerle un pin a este limbo y poder
pasar protecciones permanentes
para los jóvenes que tienen daca pero
también como otras prioridades que son
importantes como el cambio climático
este también tenemos de laxos al el
acceso al aborto perdón y tantas otras
prioridades que hoy en día podrían pasar
los demócratas pero lamentablemente
parece que hacen mucha falta de
liderazgo político en este momento y
cuál es el balance que usted hace del
programa en estos 10 años
bueno todo el mundo sabe que el programa
ha sido demasiado exitoso proveerle un
permiso de trabajo a jóvenes y no
solamente a jóvenes sino también a los
12 millones tendría un gran efecto
positivo para este país
muchas personas han tenido la
oportunidad de ingresar a la universidad
conseguir un permiso de trabajo tener
tener este una licencia de conducir
crear negocios entonces
podría ser muy beneficioso si tenemos un
camino a la ciudadanía no solamente para
el grupo de nuevo para el grupo de los
soñadores sino también para los 11
millones de indocumentados que estamos
aquí en eeuu